ferma time to potentially look look
around yes Thursday I'm currently free
on Thursday so I can kind of do morning
or afternoon but but the property looks
really good and I think it could kind of
work for what for what we're looking for
I mean I know it's you've reduced it and
it's like it looks like it's on a pretty
good price so it looks looks great um so
yeah if you let me know have you got a
few properties as well just this one
yeah I mean you know really what we're
looking for obviously some things if
something is a good price and the return
on investment is good that then that's
great
we're also sorry also another thing as
well depending on the property if it's a
property where you don't need you don't
need you're not selling it because you
need the cash you know something that we
do often is options where we can fix the
price down the line even if it's an
inflated price and then give you like a
an agreed monthly rent
in the meantime that's something as well
well let me know if you're free Thursday
we can have a look around maybe we can
chat and yeah
I really appreciate that Joe thank you
so much Pete I'm Jess bye yeah no one
wants to do a lease option agreement
that is so annoying because the thing is
these properties are in negative equity
so I can't sell them and I'm offering to
give them like a hundred and ten percent
market value but just not right yet well
what's the key it's hard no one
there's no right move there's no estate
agents there's nothing like an estate
agent is a person that you the only way
you can get em with the stages is by
knowing them and you get connected with
them basically we're just a very very
small fish in a massive sea
it was nothing it's nothing like
Sheffield may I tell you well right now
we've had about 50 doors slammed in our
face we haven't even really managed to
book a viewing we leave by the skin of
our teeth got a viewing yeah we have got
a couple of good potential viewings
lined up in Philadelphia in a few days
yeah EMV deals and things are poor
they've not confirmed we're no an attack
we're on the way bigger closer
we're on the way to go to a networking
event which is three hours away but it
was the closest thing we could find and
then tomorrow we're going to the others
we're going to like Philadelphia which
is a different state just in the hope to
actually view a house yeah
the problem is I've got a horrible
feeling that when we get to this event
that's three hours away there's gonna be
four people and two of them are gonna be
mean Alice they're poor Sarah geez
knackered our videographer can't take it
anymore because we've not eaten all day
I can't I can't go I need to just I cop
I need to eat and drink and stuff
we've got time to have been too busy
doing doing failing failing at trying to
book viewings any chance you can give us
a bit of a help from the UK maybe you
could lend us some money to do a joint
venture that'd be great doesn't seem to
be is it all seems to be there is right
move but it's all like massively
expensive houses there's nothing under a
mil and a lot of properties there's no
Gumtree it's all that Craig's List and
that's just anyway if it was you posted
how we get on but at the moment it's
sucking its yes oh no not in New York
man is not even legal in Manhattan a
rule for UK is like all the time it's
and events event you can do lease
options we're just in the wrong area I
think we just need to just be more
creative but we'll get there and offer
you tomorrow